hello there i'm greg sadler and i'm
guessing that you probably have come
across this because you've been watching
some of my youtube videos uh you might
be a subscriber to the channel
you might also be somebody who
subscribes to one of my blogs or is
connected up with me in some other way
this is a more personal video
and i'm going to start doing more and
more of these i haven't done
too many of them to this point but i'm
getting a lot of really good questions
and queries and
expressions of interest in
in
the aspect of my my
story essentially how i got into this
this philosophy bracket
and why it is that i do what i do
and one of the questions that people
have been asking me that that i've been
wanting to answer for quite a while
i had to do some thinking about it
actually
is this
i like what you're doing they say how
can i do that
and a lot of times the question is
framed in terms of i want to become a
philosophy professor
i see what you're doing you seem to like
it a lot
how can i actually become a philosophy
professor
so i'm going to start out thinking along
those lines
and give some advice about well if you
wanted that to happen what would
actually have to take place at this
point this point this point
but then i'm going to broaden it because
that's not the only way to to think
about what it is that we're doing here
there's a lot of potential for
connecting up with people for bringing
philosophy into everyday life in a way
that
that goes beyond academia
and that has much more to do with what
philosophy
was about in the sense not not the
subject matter per se but the way
philosophy was done
throughout most of history i mean
academic philosophers
are kind of a
a new and minority thing
um they've been really prevalent in the
19th and then even more in the 20th and
21st century but
people have been doing philosophy in
very public and personal ways
really since the dawn of time and
even when it was taught in schools
there's there's a lot more to the
picture than academic credits or degrees
or things like that so i want to talk
about that and give some advice about uh
you want to be a philosopher here's what
you what you want to do according to me
so i have to give a disclaimer right off
the bat
these are my views my reflections my
assessments of it a lot of people are
not going to agree with me
i'm probably leaving a lot of stuff out
because you know i'm one person and and
you tend to forget important things
but be that as it may i'm going to try
to plow through this so
let's start by thinking about
academic qualifications
if your goal is to teach
philosophy classes like intro to
philosophy all the way up to you know
graduate level classes
you know seminars say in plato or
aristotle or nietzsche or people like
that
um you need a degree
and so this is the first thing that we
should we should really
get clear about at the start if you want
to teach in a college or a university
these days
you could teach with an m.a a master's
degree
it's unlikely you're going to get a
chance to
unless it's during your your graduate
studies and you're sort of on your way
to the phd or you're what they call a
abd an all but dissertation
student who's got their m.a and is
currently writing their dissertation and
expects to defend it probably in the
first year that they get hired
why is that i mean if there was 20 years
ago 50 years ago you would see a lot of
people with amazing philosophy
and not so many people with phds well
you know the market has become saturated
with a lot of newly minted phds out
there from a lot of different programs
and so if you want to get your foot in
the door
you really want to have that that phd so
that sounds kind of daunting let's break
it down then into you know what would
have to happen along the way
uh because then it might not seem quite
so
so uh
you know
mountainous climb or something like that
you know it's not going to seem like
this this impossible task
so
the first step on the way to a phd is a
bachelor's degree an undergraduate
degree you get that at a college or
university
and
you don't necessarily have to
major in philosophy although i think
that's very helpful if you want to go on
to graduate work at philosophy
there's a lot of philosophy actually
getting done and i can do a whole other
video about why this is the case and
what it looks like
there's a lot of philosophy not being
done in philosophy departments but being
done in political science departments
history departments english departments
sociology department psychology
departments
uh
and a few others
and so i would say you know if you're an
undergraduate you want to take a wide
range of classes and and you don't
necessarily need a degree
in philosophy per se as a matter of fact
at certain schools
it might not actually be worth studying
philosophy because all they do is this
one little narrow thing here and and you
don't get much out of that
but let's say you actually do get a
degree in philosophy myself i actually
got a degree in philosophy and in
mathematics i double majored
and i i really enjoyed the math stuff
because i was doing a lot of theory work
that that coincided with philosophy
so you get your bachelor's
and now you have to go to graduate
school
and the words of advice that i would
give about graduate school and again i
could do other videos you know going
into these topics in greater depth some
other time so i'm just going to kind of
skim them here
the two things i would say are the most
important pick a graduate school
that is as high of a tier as you can go
to now what do i mean by tier there's
kind of a stratified class system in
academia shouldn't be like that but but
there is and it's not fair
and it's it's in many ways irrational
and not evidence-based because i gotta
tell you having met a lot of people from
these ivy league schools and big state
schools and having met a lot of people
from other places
talent is pretty evenly distributed
there's there's a slight preponderance
at these higher tier schools but there's
a lot of duds at higher tier schools too
and there's a lot of people who are just
sort of you know connected can you know
well connected and they got got good
positions and there's a lot of brilliant
people teaching at lower tier schools
that that could be teaching at harvard
if they knew the right people applied at
the right time if things have worked out
a bit differently for them
but if you're a graduate student you
want to go to as high a tier school as
you can
and why because quite frankly that has a
lot to do with hiring especially for
when you first go out into the job
market
that's one of the things that is part of
the class system if you go to one of
these top tier universities
that prestige that reputation attaches
to you
and
may open a lot of doors for you whereas
if you go to i can tell you this from
personal experience if you go to a lower
tier school
you are fighting an uphill battle and
you will have to you'll have to publish
more and you'll have to work a lot
harder than somebody who who came
from a uh better you know better
connected better better prepared
background in that sense
so you know i might be seen as being a
little cynical here but i you know if
that's the way the game is played
that's what you have to do
so
go in and if you can you know if you can
go to marquette instead of going and i'm
not going to start naming low tier
schools because i don't want anyone to
get upset if you can go to marquette go
to marquette if you can go to university
of north carolina chapel hill go there
if you can go to yale go to yale if you
can go and study overseas go ahead and
do that
the second thing that i think is just as
important as worrying about all this
connections and you know
job worrying you know
business is this you want to look for a
place
that
is going to teach you
is going to lead you into text is going
to help you develop help you grow
as the kind of philosopher that you want
to be
so you know
a lot of philosophy departments are
doing analytic philosophy if that's not
your thing and it's not my thing i'll
tell you right off the bat
don't go to a place that only does that
or only has one person who's doing
american philosophy or continental
philosophy or something different if
you're really into the history of
philosophy like i am
there's certain schools that you should
be looking at
and you don't want to look for just one
professor that you want to study with
you want to go to a place
where you can get some cross-infusion
from different people who are
teaching about the same
thinkers
the same you know subjects and and the
same text maybe even but are approaching
it from different angles
so if you're really really into hegel
try to find a place that actually has
not just one hegel scholar that this is
kind of tough i know but
but multiple ones or multiple people who
are at least interested in that
and also you should be aware that you
want you don't want to be too nearly
specialized going into graduate school
because your your interest may change
over time
um
so on the way in graduate school that's
all that advice stuff now what's going
to happen in graduate school
if you go to graduate school
you can expect to take a lot of
upper level classes and generally you
got to take 30 hours at the master's
level and then another 30 hours at the
phd level you're not really taking 30
hours per se because some of that is
master's thesis credits and some of that
is dissertation credits
but you know if if you're going to do it
i would actually say take as many
classes as you can possibly fit in
don't just be satisfied with doing the
bare minimum because you're preparing
yourself at a unique time that you're
never going to have the chance to do
again if you're going to actually be a
professor you're preparing yourself to
to do research and to to dig into these
these texts and you're doing it with
somebody who's a great guide
at the master's level you might have to
take some sort of comprehensive exam i
know i did
on the history of philosophy
three hours a set of questions you gotta
pick one from this column one from this
column one from this column one from
this column
and uh
expect it to the grading on that to be
rather arbitrary uh it's kind of like
part of the hazing process but it's good
because it makes you work hard it makes
you dig into these texts and get get
certain things
down cold because you need them to be
down cold for when you're going to go
into the
profession later on and start teaching
at the phd level you're going to be
taking more classes of course you're
probably going to have to take some
preliminary examinations i know i took
four
one was on metaphysics and philosophy of
religion one was on epistemology and
philosophy of science one was on what we
call value fields which would be ethics
political philosophy and aesthetics and
the fourth one at that time was on what
we called special thinker and i picked
my special thinker to be
hegel and so
how did i prepare for that
i basically memorized the phenomenology
of spirit all the different gestalton
and and how they took place i made
myself this gigantic map so i could keep
it stuck in my head
and then i also
you know intensively studied parts of
hegel's science of logic
and then same deal you know three and a
half hours
writing out these these massive essays
that's good for you though because that
means that if you can do that
you know for the these people that are
holding you to very high standards when
you get in the classroom later on or
when you're doing research on your own
you know that you have have uh
adequately prepared that some things are
almost burned into your brain i mean you
can ask me certain questions about
things i haven't read for years
and they will come back to me because i
had to drill for you know all this time
on you know learning this this material
um
then you know at the master's level you
generally have to write a
thesis
and a thesis is anywhere from about 50
to
you know 150 pages double-spaced
um
of of text and you're writing on some
problem or some thinker you're trying to
you know
do some sort of
fairly original contribution to the
field but you know you're at the
master's level so you're not doing
something that's radically new
radically innovative as it turned out
with my master's thesis i inadvertently
ended up basically replicating
uh the stuff that had already been done
by darida in his study of cultural
phenomenology and applying distil sir to
it
because i hadn't read the dairydoc at
that time
what i you know what i ended up doing
was working on hustle's passive
synthesis stuff and bringing in distal
surge raising these problems about
language
and
it was a good exercise though very very
good to actually write that out
at the at the phd level you're gonna
have to write a dissertation
now writing a dissertation means you're
basically writing a book
if i were to do things over again i
would write a totally different
dissertation than what i actually did
instead i wrote my dissertation on this
guy maurice blondell never published it
um
it ended up sprawling to something like
450 pages way too big
it's not something i'm particularly
proud of looking back at but it was a
necessary
discipline to go through it took me
about three years to research and write
it
i think if i were to go back in time and
do it i would probably write one of the
books that i'd always wanted to write on
saint anselm and the history of the
ontological proof
through uh
through
the you know medieval period the early
modern period the late modern period and
tracing out some some things a much more
manageable project
but you know you learn a lot of things
in the process not just the content that
you're you're studying but you learn
about your own capacities you learn
how to do research well and a lot of
times you have to learn this stuff by
screwing up by making dumb mistakes
that then you won't make with the next
thing down the line
myself i have to make a lot of dumb
mistakes because i'm not a person
who tends to listen to other people when
i ought to
and so they tell me hey hey don't don't
do that do this instead i'll be you know
i'll be like ah it's not that doesn't
apply to me
i'm going to do what i want to do and
then i do it and then i find out oh
there was a good reason why they said
don't do that
hopefully you're not that sort if you're
actually going to go on and try to get a
phd
so that's that's what what's involved
now after you get the phd or you know if
you're all but dissertation you go out
on the job market
and you try to get a job
and so this is the second thing i'm
going to talk about
and this is kind of a this is kind of a
downer
the job market right now for higher
education is is pretty bad
part of it has to do with the economic
downturn but it's been bad for quite a
while
even during the sort of heyday stock
market high days
it's not been very good compared to
previous generations i would estimate
that every position i've applied for in
the last three four years there are
anywhere from 300 to 500 applicants
and a lot of them went to much better
schools have better contacts
may have a better publication record
than i do
you know are working at better schools
all those are things that affect your
job your job prospects because those are
things that a lot of people whether they
tell you they do or not are actually
looking to when they're going through
those 300 applications they want to see
where you went to who you know who
vouches for you what you've published
and where you're currently teaching so
if you're not already currently teaching
somewhere you want to get some teaching
experience when you're a graduate school
a graduate student you want to try to
get teaching assistantships so that you
can ultimately have your own classes and
teach those get some experience when you
go on the market
um it's tough to get hired and it's a
very alienating process
the profession actually makes it worse
than it has to be there's you know
for example if you go to the american
philosophical association
which is where they do a lot of the the
early interviews the first stage of
interviews where they'll interview
anywhere from 10 to 16 people for one
job
that's usually over the christmas
holiday so you don't get to spend time
with your family uh except at christmas
and then you know like the 28th 29th
30th you got to be stuck somewhere like
new york or boston or philadelphia or
atlanta
and you got to pay a lot of money for a
hotel room you got to fly out there
and then they'll they'll have like this
entire gigantic ballroom just filled up
with tables with schools that are that
are carrying on interviews and you know
you got to go at this time meet with
these people and they'll ask you a whole
bunch of questions they're probably not
happy that they had to skip you know a
good portion of their break
um it's very alienating the whole
process and intimidating
but you know i guess i could do a video
on on tips on how to get through that
sort of thing uh because because um i
think i
get through that much better than some
other people in my field
um
in part because a lot of times i just
don't care right i i'm i'm you know
somebody doesn't like me um i'm not
particularly concerned about that
even when i should be
but
that's you know if you get past that
stage then you do the on-campus
interviews and they'll bring in two
sometimes four people to do an on-campus
interview
when you go there you're probably going
to be observed teaching you're going to
do some sort of presentation you're
going to have to meet with a lot of
people
and then you know the whole process is
one kind of big black box either you'll
not hear anything which means that
they're probably trying to get somebody
else to take the job
or they make you an offer
and i gotta tell you you know it's it's
tough getting jobs my my
uh first
two main jobs that i i've taught and my
situation was a little bit different
than many other people
i taught in a maximum security prison
for six years teaching philosophy and
religious studies classes for ball state
university
and then i had to get on the job market
right away and then my next job was at a
low tier
historically black college that was
really really struggling
fayetteville state university
now i'm teaching for marist but i'm just
teaching part-time
and there's not a lot of a lot of
positions open right now i i keep my eye
up but i don't want to relocate myself
unless it's like a the ideal job
so i'm not applying to
very much stuff currently
if you get a phd in philosophy and you
want to work in the field
you're going to have to be willing to
apply
all over the place so you might have to
teach some place that's very far
removed from where you currently are
just because of the way that the market
is currently
you get a bit more leverage the more
people that you know
uh the better place that you're teaching
the more experience you have the more
that you publish
the more
central or important your publications
are that gives you a bit more leverage
there's other things that can give you a
bit more leverage too you know doing
administrative work is a really smart
job
because that that you know shows that
you you have a sort of flexibility
there's other things too i mean you want
to
devote a lot of time to being a good
teacher
because most of the places that are
hiring are not hiring you to do this
top-tier
research you know just focused on
aristotle and the problem of this or
that they're hiring you to teach a whole
bunch of service classes
that's probably enough about that
so like i said you know that's that's a
bit of a downer now let's talk about
stuff that i think is a bit more
fun and and should make you a bit more
optimistic
do you actually need a degree in
philosophy do you need to go to
university and pump in all these years
and and you know write a master's thesis
and write a phd in order to make
philosophy a central part of your life
and engage with others in philosophy and
perhaps even do some teaching no
absolutely not
i mean look at what's going on right now
i'm talking to you through the medium of
this
flip cam
now that flip cam is over there and this
flip cam is here but i mean this is a
70 or 100 piece of technology the tripod
costs another
um
10 bucks at staples
and
you have to have a computer to hook it
up to granted but you know most people
have computers these days and video
software
isn't very uh difficult to get your
hands on
and if you want to talk philosophy
well you can do it through this sort of
thing do it through youtube i mean
just go and look at some of the comments
on some of my my videos we sometimes get
these these really
deep philosophical conversations going
on if somebody asks a great question and
i want to make a video response kind of
like i'm doing right now
that's available to me
google now has these hangouts where you
can actually you know skype you could do
this before
but now you know google has these
hangouts where you can share data with
each other
and you can you can talk about something
and you've got all these different
people on video at the same time
it's like a classroom google actually
now has online classes i've just started
exploring this but they have online
classes that you can actually create and
then teach not for credit of course but
you know credit is not the most
important thing in the world
if what you're really interested in
is studying philosophy because it's
something that's worthwhile it brings
value to your own existence
you like it you have a passion for it
you don't have to do it in a university
or a college
you can do it online
you can do it by by finding the people
who are willing to to do that sort of
work and you can become that sort of
person
you know i gotta say when it comes down
to it
a lot of the the study that i did that
goes into
the kind of work that i do and what i
know and what i'm passionate about
that didn't happen through my my
graduate study let alone my
undergraduate i was a screw-up as an
undergrad i you know spent more time
uh drinking and chasing women and
and uh you know
gallivanting around doing all sorts of
crazy things and you know playing bass
and stuff like that that i did studying
and i really read whatever i wanted to
read rather than just what the professor
assigned
but in graduate school i buckled down
but even what i learned in grad school
that's just a small portion
of what it is that
i decided i wanted to learn on my own
you can do that too and there's all
these great resources out there
one of the ones i've been experimenting
with lately that i think shows a lot of
potential is learnest
and you can create courses and you can
connect it up with material that's
available on on the net anybody can do
it
because they're i think they're out of
beta now
so if you want to teach philosophy
i would say
you you can do that without having a phd
you might not get as many people
necessarily coming to you but
i don't know that even having a phd
unless you have like a name or
reputation
helps you out too much with that
you have to generate quality content
you have to
give other people something that
improves their life
that helps them
understand their issues or helps them
understand this philosopher in this text
that entertains them to some degree
that
they find compelling and if you do that
people are going to watch you or if
you're say blogging if you want to do a
philosophy blog
start one up bloggers available
wordpress is available i know there's a
lot of other ones
i encourage everybody who wants to do
this this sort of work
with
taking philosophy and and making it more
accessible to to other people and saying
what you think about it and telling
people what what excites you about this
text or this thinker and exploring
examples all that sort of stuff you want
to do that go ahead and do it
if you're watching this you probably
have a youtube account
get yourself a flip cam and a tripod and
start shooting some videos and don't
expect it to be great from the start if
you look at some of my earlier videos i
don't like them very much at all
you know sometimes the camera is shaky
or you know they end too early because i
forgot to charge it fully
but you know
my point here i guess i'm rambling a
little bit my point here is if you want
to do this kind of kind of work
if you want to get into this racket
use the educational technology and the
social media
networking stuff that's out there
and just start doing it
i i
i'm you know totally surprised at how
much this this could take off
i have to credit my wife too my wife was
one of these these people who said if
you build it they will come and i was
very skeptical about the idea of putting
videos up on on youtube or starting a
blog or any of that sort of stuff who's
going to be interested in this
you don't know until you actually put it
out there so
you know go ahead and do that and if you
want to go to university and study
philosophy and get a phd go ahead and do
that but if you want to read philosophy
on your own in your own home
there's nothing to prevent you from
buying the the same books and if you
want to study epictetus
you can read epictetus and if you want
to learn how to read epictetus in greek
you can learn how to read greek and then
you know you can you can get yourself
one of these lobe classic that has the
greek and the
english on facing pages so that way you
know if you can't figure out sometimes
what's being said over here you look
over here for a little clue
but my point is
this is within everybody's reach if you
really have a passion for philosophy
if you really want to to do it then
nothing's stopping you other than
uh time
and resources
and um juggling priorities
so the fourth thing i want to say is you
know
if you're going to study philosophy
if you're already studying philosophy
and you want to teach it to other people
here's what i think is really necessary
having a degree
that's not really necessary
having intellectual curiosity having a
hunger for knowledge
having that sort of attitude of nothing
nothing philosophical
nothing
valuable is alien to me that you you
know you want to know you want to
find out what different people have
thought you want to
engage them you want you know after
you've read one text you want to read
the next text
if you have that kind of desire
that's going to carry you a very long
way
that's the kind of desire that
we professors
love to see in students
because i think
that's kind of a sign that hey that
person
they're kind of like me
i mean we get into this racket
at least those of us who love what we do
because it lets us read books and
commune with the great ancient and
medieval and modern thinkers for a
living
to get paid to actually talk to people
about aristotle and plato i mean how
cool is that
um
so you need that intellectual curiosity
you you also need some training you know
before you want i always tell my
students before you you tell me about
your opinions tell me what aristotle
thought because aristotle probably is
smarter than either one of us and i'd
kind of like to hear about what he has
to say before i hear your shtick
and then you know see if your schtick
actually lines up with his or you know
if you disagree with him tell me why and
have some reasons
if you want to do philosophy well
this is one of my beefs actually with
analytic philosophy i think you there's
no substitute for actually studying a
wide range of thinkers across the ages
who comprise what we can call the canon
of philosophy you have to read plato you
have to read aristotle you have to read
augustine you have to read thomas
aquinas you have to read thomas hobbs
and we can keep going on from from there
and if you're not willing to do that
you know if you say i only want to focus
on nietzsche well you know hey nietzsche
spent a lot of time studying aristotle
and plato and kant and all these other
people before he started writing his own
stuff so if you really want to
understand nietzsche and you want to get
all the references to what he's talking
about you want to be able to evaluate it
you got to read the people he read
there's there's no way around it
um
you know you don't want to specialize in
this tiny little niche here
and say i'm only going to read you know
the these these thinkers who are only
talking to each other and only reading
each other because that's like being in
a clique
i mean this entire vast world of
philosophy has opened up to you
it's free on the web i mean if you want
to read kierkegaard you can find him
online if you want to read plato you can
find him online if you want to read st
anselm hey go to jasper hopkins website
where he's got his own translations in
pdf form these beautiful little you know
book things
for free
if you want
to know what people think about this
google it and and you know blogs and
youtube videos and other things all
these sort of resources will pop up you
can you can study what you want to study
um so it's important to engage ideas but
it's important to engage thinkers in
texts
there's certain
things you should keep going back to i
mean i'm still teaching the republic
semester after semester and i'm still
finding stuff in there that i missed the
last time and i've been reading that
book for over 20 years
and i can say the same thing about a lot
of other texts as well
you also want is another tip you want to
find ways to connect philosophy up with
your own life
now you don't want to just study things
that have to do with you and your own
life
you want to instead you know read the
philosophy and then bring your own life
into
connect with it make your own life grow
you don't want to just start out okay
these are my little narrow conceptions
and here's my life and now that one over
there that ties in with this i'm going
to read that one and pay attention to it
you don't want to do that you want your
life to grow you want you your
personality to to to expand prosper to
flourish right
so what you want to do is when you're
reading plato you want to try to see the
world the way plato does not so that you
can become a convert and now you know
everything you know is viewed through
plato colored glasses or something like
that
but so that you can try on
intellectually and imaginatively even
experientially
what it was that this guy was about what
it was that drove him to to write this
stuff down
what it was that he shared with us
same thing for aristotle same thing for
epictetus same thing for
kant for nietzsche for hegel for you
know john paul sartre for all these
different thinkers you want to connect
it up with your own life
the last thing i'm going to say
and this is
really a fruit of my own bitter
experience
don't be too concerned
with originality
i'm going to say that again
don't be too concerned with originality
you don't have to do
something radically new that nobody else
has ever done before
you don't have the pressure to come up
with your own
philosophy of life to
be the next great star or something like
that
it's enough to actually understand just
what the hell plato was saying
that's valuable by itself
that's an achievement
that's something worthwhile
if you do that and you understand what
aristotle happened to say
that's two big achievements
now you add in epictetus or cicero or
pick whoever you like
these are these are great things to do
you don't actually have to come up with
something
radically original in order for what you
do to be valuable
the stuff that you're studying if you're
studying philosophy is is inherently
worthwhile
getting into these ideas is like
entering into a cathedral
you don't need to build another
cathedral
one is is good enough explore that see
what's in there
and then talk with other people about
that
i don't aim to do
here i originally got caught in that
originality trap originally got caught
at the originality track that's kind of
funny um
and it produced a lot of anxiety and
even something like a depression on my
part when i was a graduate student and
and i i got through it in part because i
got thrown into teaching and just you
know hit the ground running and couldn't
look back for quite a while
and it took me learning experientially
that going into these thinkers and texts
by itself is is going to make me happy
you know mastering what anselm said
about this exploring what thomas aquinas
is doing over here figuring out what the
hell you know heidegger or hegel or
husserole or pick whoever you like is
talking about that's going to make me
pretty happy
i'm going to be in touch with something
i had to learn that the hard way
i had to learn that by by
um years and years of experience
so what i would say to you is just get
you know skip ahead
um
be okay with
figuring out what marcus or adorno or
derrida is saying or you know what
leibniz is saying
and and you know digging into it and
trying to
unpack it and and you know figure out
its structure and its purpose
you don't have to reinvent the wheel
there's enough people out there trying
to do that all you have to do is get
some things down
and then you can talk about them with
other people i mean i think there's a
lot more people that are interested to
hear
what i have to say about what plato's
saying than what i have to say as
gregory sadler
i didn't that makes perfect sense
plato's a much smarter guy who had you
know contributed a lot more than than i
you know am likely to do
so you know what i'm i guess what i'm
saying here
really boils down to a sense of
cultivate a sense of humility
originality the the need to to be
original is really a form of
intellectual pride i would say
um
and
it's self-destructive
humility is um
it's very fulfilling
you know getting to to hang out with
plato for a while
and then hang out with other people who
like plato
and and you know
expand on well what would plato have
said if you know he ran into this
that's fun
that's engaging that's exciting
and again to come back to the whole you
know thing that ties it all together
this is what you can do so you know if
you're asking me the question hey i
would like to do what you do i'm sharing
with you a little bit about how i got to
where i am
and what it is that i do what i do is is
read philosophy and talk about it with
people
and hopefully get them get them to see
what's going on over there not with me
but what's going on over there with the
texts
with the thinkers
and
how it might improve their own lives
so is there anything that would keep you
from being able to do that uh no and is
is not having a degree a barrier to that
does that you know fence you out
absolutely not because you can you know
use the technology that that's there to
to engage with other people and so i
encourage all of you who have an
interest in doing that to
do precisely that i would love to see
tons of youtube channels with with not
necessarily professionals but just
amateurs in the sense of people who love
what they're doing
talking philosophy